Twitter's troubles appear to be
worsening it's closing its offices until
a Monday after hundreds of employees
reportedly quit the new boss Elon Musk
had given staff the option of signing up
to what he called a hardcore Twitter or
leave with three months severance pay
the deadline for workers to decide
passed several hours ago a disabled
employee who was fired for refusing to
return to the office is now suing the
company Twitter is also facing legal
action for previous layoffs he ensures
an editor at large with CNET that's a
technology website and he suspects
Twitter staff are choosing to leave the
company because of musk's management
style
he is known for being a very hard
charging CEO who has extreme demands of
his employees right we've seen him talk
about sleeping on the floor of the Tesla
plants we saw after he took over Twitter
that some of the people inside Twitter
were bringing in their their sleeping
bags and having to stay overnight there
and we we know that he was pushing them
very hard what I think is interesting is
that this was one of the first times
that he let the employees tell him what
they think of all of this and that was
by him saying either you're going to
sign up and say you're going to follow
along with this minimum 40 hour work
week I expect you in the office or you
can walk out the door and it seems
according to a lot of reports that a lot
of people took the door it's very clear
I think that Elon Musk realizes maybe
that he doesn't have very many friends
in the office right now uh which you
know it's hard to have a lot of friends
when you've cut half the staff and then
uh tried to kind of uh get a bunch of
other more people to go by telling them
that they're doing a terrible job and
and you know just kind of generally
causing a lot of stress so I think the
question is where is this all going to
go right is is Twitter suddenly going to
be significantly smaller than it started
I mean just earlier this month it was 7
500 employees then it went down to some
3 500. According to some reports it is
dropped down to a drop down by 88
percent that's unbelievable number of
people to walk out the door inside a
month